pepinster in belgium is a village
upended built at the confluence of two
rivers
and completely vulnerable when they
turned into torrents
miriam and her family live at the
water's edge her home
is ruined and she is confident of the
driving force behind what happened
i think it's a it's a consequence we say
in english
of the claim change because it's
it's not normal we have many
many times it was raining but
nothing like that we can explain that
we can't there is no road to explain
that we don't know
how it's possible i don't want to stay
here anymore
no you don't want to be next to the
water no
no it's finished i don't know how we we
are going
to do because we have our house here
the damage is widespread and ongoing
some buildings
burning however odd that may seem in the
circumstances
others are collapsing
in this case right behind the mayor as
he tried to do a television interview
a demonstration if it were needed of the
fragility
of our urban lives scientists say that
although it's
hard to directly and definitively link
single events to climate change
it does make extreme weather more
frequent and more severe
increasingly they say the fingerprints
of climate change can be found
on catastrophic flooding heat waves and
drought
it's like lung cancer and smoking
but we can say for sure that there is a
strong correlation
between climate change and the risk the
exacerbated risk
of intense rainfall what we used to
consider exceptional
has become the new normality there will
be no
return to the climate that we used to
know some 20 or 30 years ago
it leaves villages like pepinsta to
wonder about the future
if western europe is going to start to
experience more of this
then adaption is going to become
increasingly important
communities forced to rethink how and
where and whether to build
how to best protect homes and properties
and businesses
and infrastructure for when it happens
next time
how to live with climate change as it
reshapes our world
hannah thomas peter sky news in
pepinster belgium